when paramedics were called to this
luxury apartment block in Manhattan
they found Lorenz Scott unconscious and
unresponsive Scott's assistant had
discovered her reportedly hanging by a
scarf she was declared dead at the scene
the 49 year olds longtime boyfriend rock
star Mick Jagger is on tour in Australia
his spokesperson said the Rolling Stones
frontman was completely shocked and
devastated by the news I think it's
going to take a lot of people by
surprise I mean perhaps her very
intimate friends might know about a kind
of troubled side to her I think the only
indication that we have that there was
perhaps anything amiss whatsoever was
when she sort of abruptly cancelled her
fashion show at London Fashion Week this
was something that was unprecedented in
terms of her and it was a surprise and
she cited production issues but it was
never really entirely explained what
those were raised in Utah by adoptive
parents Scott made her name as a model
turned celebrated clothing designer her
creations worn by celebrities like
Penelope Cruz Victoria Beckham and
Nicole Kidman she is being mourned as a
lost talent fashion designer Marc Jacobs
tweeted rest in peace Lauren Scott you
will forever be missed but reports have
suggested behind the glamour and jet-set
lifestyle her business was struggling
losing cash and heavily in debt there's
been no suggestion this was anything
other than a suicide but New York's
Medical Examiner's still to formally
determine the cause of death
Scott's publicist released a statement
requesting privacy for her friends and
family at this devastating time Hanna
Thomas Peter Sky News New York
you